Cómo avanzábamos directo aquí en France
24 y en esta ocasión lo hacemos desde
nuestro estudio junto a nuestro
periodista Judith Muñoz con quien
haremos un repaso a las dos jornadas de
protestas en Colombia tanto a favor como
en contra del gobierno de Gustavo
petróleois bienvenida a este estudio qué
tal Rodrigo un gusto estar aquí Un gusto
tenerte también aquí como decía dos
jornadas de protesta en la capital
colombiana y en todo el país el martes
el propio Gustavo Petro convocó una
marcha a favor de tres de sus
principales reformas clave hoy ha habido
marcha en contra de la oposición Cuál es
el balance de estas protestas Rodrigo la
verdad que pocas conclusiones podemos
extraer Ya que ni ayer se vio como un
apoyo masivo al presidente Gustavo Petro
ni hoy tampoco en unos números similares
de participación en las calles tampoco
se ha visto un gran rechazo por parte
del presidente Gustavo Petro hemos visto
que ha vuelto al lugar donde se siente
más cómodo a la oratoria a la plaza
pública y ha sido un momento que Para
apoyar esas reformas que comentaba se ha
apoyado Pues en volver al discurso de
campaña ese cambio
ese utilizar al pueblo como el
responsable de llevar adelante las
reformas y también ha prometido la fin
del neoliberalismo pero como decía no es
que hubiese muchísima gente pero con Los
partidarios como estuvimos en las calles
pudimos hablar hablaban de de cómo estas
reformas son importantes sobre todo para
ese espectro social de Colombia que está
sufriendo necesidades del lado de la
oposición hemos visto más como una
jornada de catarsis como una forma de
desahogarse con muchos gritos enérgica
pero también con una cantidad de
personas similar en las calles han
llegado a la plaza Bolívar la céntrica
tres cuartas partes llena y es eso no
tanta gente también igual que las de
Petro y lo que hemos visto También en
esta oposición es que no hay como
grandes figuras clave Incluso el
expresidente Álvaro uribea ha mantenido
silencio respecto a estas convocatorias
tampoco había como muchos mensajes
claros sino que más bien la protesta
estaba centrada en Gustavo Petro al que
relacionan pues su pasado guerrillero y
también pues le relacionan estos
manifestantes con su como si fuese un
comunista y que podría llevar al país a
ser una Venezuela o Cuba Bueno y si
había sido un inicio tranquilo de
legislatura para Gustavo Petro y para su
gobierno quizás con algunas polémicas
pero sí que es verdad que ahora se agita
la actividad política en Colombia que
está por venir en estos próximos meses
sobre todo son estas tres reformas
sociales que comentábamos y la primera
la más importante con la que ha tenido
más prisa Gustavo Petro es la reforma a
la salud que fue radicada el lunes en el
congreso y que tendrá que ser aprobada
por este mismo congreso por los
congresistas tanto en la cámara de
representantes como en el senado y esta
reforma la salud lo que pretende es un
aumento de la atención primaria pero
también pasaron un sistema un modelo que
tenga una mayor un mayor peso lo público
después vendrán otras dos reformas que
también tuvieron espacio en su discurso
ayer en la plaza pública y en la Plaza
de Armas en su residencia y son laboral
y la pensional que todavía no conocemos
el texto por lo que sí que estamos
viendo Es que Gustavo Petro en este
primer año que todavía no ha llegado
quiere llevar adelante las grandes
reformas de lo que será su gobierno como
ya fue también la reforma tributaria con
la que aumentó en 4.000 millones de
dólares el presupuesto anual y también
pues además de las sociales también
habrá espacio para reforma a la justicia
Y es que también próximamente el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro quiere sacar
adelante la ley del sometimiento que le
permita hacer negociaciones colectivas
con bandas armadas que se dediquen al
Crimen y al narcotráfico Y es que sí que
está pudiendo negociar ya con bandas
armadas que tienen un origen político
como es el ejército de liberación
nacional la guerrilla activa más antigua
de América Latina